- I'm gonna fuck this shit up,
I already know.
(jazzy music)
- Today we're gonna be guessing
famous black movie quotes.
- I am nervous.
I don't wanna get it wrong.
I would like to keep my black card.
- I think I'll at least be decent,
but I hope to do very well.
- I don't think I'm gonna do well at all.
I'm one of those black girls that's like,
yeah, I'm black, but by default.
Like, I'm a military kid.
I grew up in Asia.
- Oh, man, top three.
Obviously Love And Basketball.
- Soul Food was important
to me, The Best Man.
- I'd only have like,
one solid black movie.
- Alright, let's do this.
- Oh my god, Ricky!
- This one.
Where is this from?
Wait, play it again.
- Ricky?
Gunshot?
That's Boyz N The Hood for sure.
- That's Boyz N The Hood.
Boyz N The Hood.
- That's what it is?
How did I not know that?
- Oh my God.
(laughter)
- Bye Felicia!
- Come on, this is Friday.
- Friday.
- If you're black and
have never seen Friday,
I'm gonna take away your black card.
- Oh my God, what is
the name of this movie?
- Friday.
- Oh my God, it's on the tip of my tongue.
- This is Friday.
- Friday!
Jesus Christ, are you kidding me?
I'm so mad at myself.
- Oh my God.
- Anna Mae don't want this cake, okay.
- Oh, no.
- Tina Turner, Ike and -- right?
Tina Turner, what is it called?
Isn't it the name of
the movie, Ike and Tina?
What's Love Got To Do With It!
Gimme that point.
- I'm supposed to guess that?
- It's Ike and Turner.
- What's Love Got To Do With It.
- I think it's The Color Purple?
- Anna Mae, who is Anna Mae?
I'm gonna go with Dopey and Menace.
- I'm gonna say The Color Purple.
I'm wrong, damn.
- Getting competitive, now.
Got sweat on my forehead.
- Oh.
- Tell him, Taraji.
- I hate yo ass, you make me sick.
- I'mma just let it finish.
- They're talking about
Baby Boy right now.
- Baby Boy.
For a second, I was like,
who's that talking right now?
Taraji.
- Baby Boy.
- Baby Boy, what?
- I'm putting cases on all you bitches.
Okay, Denzel.
- Classic, iconic.
- I don't know this.
- It's so much, like --
(pounding)
- I know that's Denzel,
he's in a thousand movies.
I'm gonna assume this is Training Day.
- Training Day.
- Is it Paid In Full?
- And I've seen Training Day, what?
- I did it, that was a lot of fun.
I wish I could do it more.
- I think black film is
important, obviously,
because of representation.
- We are already misrepresented
in the media, and I
think having black films,
you can see yourself in different lights.
- For me, the movies that resonate with me
the most are the movies that have people
that look like me, talk
like me, act like me.
- I get to walk outta
here with my black card
intact, and keep being
unapologetically black.